viele menschen fragen sich wie soll man
gegen die korona politik protestieren
zum beispiel gegen die impfpflicht
demonstrieren macht das nicht das sagt
jetzt ausgerechnet unsere neue
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser sie
ruft dazu auf dass man nicht mit vielen
anderen gemeinsam seine meinung kundtun
sollte ja und das macht sie mit einem
tweet mit diesem tweet ihr dort schreibt
sie man kann seine meinung auch kundtun
ohne sich gleichzeitig an vielen orten
zu versammeln schauen sie auf das was
nancy faeser unsere neue
bundesinnenministerium hier getwittert
hat sie fordert uns also auf unser
grundrecht nicht wahrzunehmen
bild -chef johannesburg bei uns im
studio schönen guten tag johannes du
sagst das ist nicht nur merkwürdig das
ist ein skandal ja ich sehe das ok in
der tat denn wir wissen alle
im grundgesetz heißt
es eindeutig die deutschen jeder
deutsche hat das recht sich zu
versammeln ja ich zitiere etwas verkürzt
bin kein jurist aber die bundes
innenministerin sollte das wissen was
sie hier ja letzten endes tut ist sie
verbietet das nicht sieht auch nur ihre
eigene meinung kommt aber sie empfiehlt
endes eben doch
dass die deutschen ihr grundrecht nicht
ausübten
gehört sich für eine ministerin nicht
die meinungsfreiheit gilt für alle
deutschen auch für die innenministerin
aber sie müsste sich eben auch daran
erinnern dass sie nicht nur für sie gilt
sondern auch für das ganze volk wie
findest du wie bewertest du dass
johannes überhaupt wie steht es um
unsere grundrechte in dieser pandemie da
haben ganz viele bürgerinnen und bürger
sorge ja auch ich habe sorge ich finde
das problem ist vielleicht nicht ganz so
groß wie es manche unter den corona
demonstranten behaupten wir leben nicht
in einer diktatur wir haben nicht die
grundrechte komplett abgeschafft aber
das erkannt die grundrechte wurden
anders gewichtet in der pandemie und
zwar gleich mehrfach und selbst wenn man
der meinung ist dass das notwendig ist
und dass das aus pandemischen gründen
zur gesundheitsvorsorge sein muss muss
man ja auch sagen hier
eine schieflage die demokratie und man
muss dann sehr scharf und sehr genau
darauf achten wann wird denn die andere
gewichtung und rechte ehrlich gesagt ich
finde man kann auch sagen die
einschränkung der grundrechte wieder
abgeschafft und das dauert mir ganz
entschieden zu lang und ich sehe eben an
äußerungen wie der von frau feser dass
diese reflexion in der bundesregierung
bei einigen gar nicht in diesem ausmaß
vorhanden ist in dem sie eigentlich
vorhanden sein müsste eigentlich würde
ich erwarten dass politikerinnen und
politiker die ganze zeit im hinterkopf
haben wir schränken gerade die
grundrechte der bevölkerung ein wir
haben es über zwei jahre hinweg oder um
zwei jahre hinweg immer wieder getan das
ist etwas ganz besonderes was wir hier
tun und unser oberstes ziel muss es sein
hier wieder rauszukommen und ein
vollkommen normales miteinander zu
erleben natürlich nur dann wenn es die
pandemie erlaubt aber doch als oberstes
ziel der politik kann ich im moment
nicht erkennen kann ich in anbetracht
von frau street überhaupt nicht erkennen
eine bundesinnenministerium eine neue
nancy faeser also die man eben am handy
twittert und uns dazu auffordert nicht
zu demonstrieren nicht zu vielen an
vielen orten seine meinung zu sagen
nicht von diesem grundrecht gebrauch zu
machen das zeugt nicht von allzu viel
respekt uns gegenüber vor allem den
grundgesetz gegenüber und in dieses bild
passt auch wie der vizekanzler robert
habeck damit umgeht das jetzt ja gegen
ihn und gegen die komplette
grünen-spitze staatsanwaltschaftlich
ermittelt wird dazu sagte robert habeck
ja gestern dass
[Musik]
die ermittlungen der staatsanwaltschaft
in berlin sind ja auf den bekannten
vorgängen die im letzten jahr schon im
wahlkampf dargestellt wurden aufbauend
insofern mehrfach politisch
durchgenudelt
chefredakteur johannes boie weiterhin
bei uns politisch ist das ganze schon
durchgenudelt dass also das statement
vom vizekanzler roberts
ist es bei dir auch verständnis dass das
jetzt genug durchgenudelt ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen überhaupt nicht und wir
haben wirklich gesagt lasst uns der
neuen bundesregierung eine chance geben
lasst uns objektiv gucken wie machen sie
ihren job es gab einiges wirklich in den
letzten wirklich auch gefreut hat sich
richtig fand das hat auch bild immer
wieder betont annalena baerbock wie sie
in russland so weiter und so fort aber
das also ich meine wenn die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittlungen einleite
das ist über den zustand einer
vorprüfung geht um den anfangsverdacht
von daten des deutschen vize kanzlers
auch da würde ich von ihm selbst dann
mehr respekt für die ermittlungen der
staatsanwaltschaft erwarten dass
juristische system ist in deutschland
zum glück sehr stark
sein dass er das beiseite wischt mit
politisch durchgenudelt selbst wenn er
selbst der meinung ist er sei komplett
unschuldig selbst wenn die opposition
dies ausschlachtet ja gut das gehört
alles dazu aber man muss doch von den
obersten spitzen des staates einen
absoluten respekt für die ermittelnden
organe des staates erwarten denn das ist
ja auch was was wir jetzt immer wieder
diskutieren was auch die politikerinnen
und politiker zu recht diskutieren ist
der respekt vor dem start noch da ist
der respekt vor der polizei davor den
staatsanwaltschaften und man sieht das
genau bei den gruppen die jetzt auch auf
die straße gehen gegen die sich dann die
politik wir sprachen gerade darüber
in einer womöglich nicht angemessenen
härte kümmert dass es bei denen der der
respekt vor
staatsanwaltschaften und polizisten
verloren geht aber dann muss doch der
vizekanzler gerade sagen ich gehe hier
mit gutem beispiel voraus nehme das
ernst stelle mich dem verfahren
mehr respekt sagt der bischof johannes
wo ihr für uns für unser grundgesetz für
die institutionen in diesem fall robert
habeck ebenfalls hier ist nichts
durchgenudelt wenn die
staatsanwaltschaft zeiten noch er mit
vielen dank